the world is ending yet again the latest
existential terror Justice Kennedy
hanging up his robe
could he be giving it up for this one I
would it's time to relax he's 81 years
old come on give the guy a break
still I wonder if we're screwed oh we
are supremely screwed in some ways it
feels like all hope is dead in some ways
it feels like all hope is dead forever
you're on Comedy Central what part of
that title are you forgetting thank god
this hysteria isn't contagious if he's
gone and they replace him with a classic
one of these Mike Pence type Republicans
god help us
what's the court gonna look like the
next 30 we're looking at a destruction
of the Constitution of the United States
the only way that we're going to stop
this is eventually we're all gonna have
to put our bodies on the line oh I feel
bad for that line the medical term for
this losing their I can't blame them the
guy they hate is doing pretty good and
we have nicer boats we got nicer boats
yeah I told you I wouldn't lie about
Knights or boats so how do we respond to
this widespread panic I'm torn
should I get after it Chris there is a
lot to tackle tonight what do you say
let's get after let's get out what do
you say let's get after it the new happy
hour according to one of our fans so
what do you say let's get em yes let's
get after it every day something happens
in the media announces the end of the
world and what it doesn't happen they
act like they never said it they did it
with the Paris Accords North Korea tax
cuts now this and the fact that they're
always wrong it doesn't stop them
mayflies have longer long term memory
and they croak in two hours so time to
replace the boy who cried wolf fable
with the hosts who scream apocalypse
the average anchor is now the freak on
the street corner wearing his mother's
wedding dress with a golf bag over it
screaming that the end is so near it was
actually last week so what happens if we
truly have an apocalyptic problem will
the public even listen what if something
truly bad happens like Costco running
out of Kirkland Signature Italian style
meatballs they are amazing I eat them
frozen in the dark alone still I wonder
should I get after it there is a lot to
tackle tonight what do you say let's get
after let's get after what do you say
let's get after it the new happy hour
according to one of our fans so what do
you say let's get em now remember when
this week was about civility everybody
was calling for it even cable news yeah
these guys they got 49 votes no big
names so my question is political
strategy
we're Democrat to get a Republican upon
this there you go
and now everybody wants calm and they're
right now we got a congress woman
encouraging conflict we got people
heckled at homes while others are
harassed at restaurants it's like the
dawn of the dead except it's feelings
and not zombies that are eating us alive
so where does this end I mean what
happens if all restaurants started to
discriminate based on their personal
preferences maybe one already does are
you tired of being kicked out of
restaurants halfway through your meal
because someone finds you problematic
don't you wish you could know you're not
welcome before you went inside from the
founders of passel B's and out back
judge house comes snub way it's the only
restaurant where you can't even enter
until you've been thoroughly vetted as a
person hi welcome to snub way-hey to
please I have this picture of you from
2013 where you're wearing a man bun I'm
gonna have to ask you to leave it's just
a phase hi there's no statute of
limitations on for life decisions next
hi we have a reservation it's our
anniversary
oh great just one question what's your
favorite TV show to watch together oh
that's easy we love the view you can
serve your kind here next and even if
you do manage to get into snub way you
won't last long because we'll learn
everything about you until we find
something we disagree with excuse me sir
I see that here you went on a 14 tweet
rant harassing Lou Dobbs and yet there's
a baby as your profile picture is that
your child yes
so get out you're eating with him you're
just as guilty beat it loser snub way
we're so picky about our business that
we rarely have any at all
and fine acting all right so could this
harassment get any worse I don't know
the good thing is most people have jobs
so you don't go around shouting at
people if you got a sales call in the
morning the jerks chasing people around
they aren't commanding a sales force
they're barely commanding clean
underwear my advice were libs focus on
ideas and not people demonizing never
ends well for anyone call someone a Nazi
and you end the discussion before it
starts so my solution it's kind of
sincere even naive and it might get me
laughed out of here but I think we need
a peace movement and we need the right
to start it because to expect one from
the left
it's just silly right now they're in a
state and everything to them is a
helpless calamity they don't like us
much it's one outstretched hand must
come from us now Trump did it with North
Korea Netanyahu is trying with Iran
could we do it with our fellow Americans
maybe now your generosity may not be
reciprocated but before we decide to
match anger with anger why not take the
high ground if it still goes bad at
least you know you did your best when
they're at their worst
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guests
he's obviously let himself go his
washboard abs are not washboard flabs
retired Green Beret Master Sergeant
Terry Schappert he's crushed more sets
than Godzilla in Legoland his latest
book is called everybody is awful except
you and it's excellent
after comedian jim Florentine she sulker
than a bowl of barroom peanuts National
Review reporter Katherine Tim he can
make mountains look like Moe Hills
former WWE Superstar my massive sidekick
Tyrus
all right Carrie um what do you what do
you think of my idea am i stupid no I
actually think it's kind of a that's a
very nice idea it's it's got it's gotten
merit a couple things yes um the doves
are pretty clever about this I was
driving the other day and I heard Rachel
Maddow they were playing - stop - she
was saying she actually said this and I
I think she might believe in you know
Dems we don't we don't go for radical
things we're the ones you're trying to
play by the rules and I let I left I did
the little rascals triple take in my car
I went because I was like are you
kidding me mad that's exactly what they
don't do but let me say this America
what do not forget yeah if your movement
goes that's great but I will tell you
now do not forget in the last couple
years what the left is said about you do
not forget what they've called for you
to submit to do not forget what they
stand for
do not forget all the things they have
done because they're gonna try to sweet
but are you smirking at me yeah I just
realized there goes my peace movement if
you actually remember what the left us
to you there dude you know 25-year Green
Beret I don't forget so I will I will -
pulled out the olive branch but I'm just
telling you now I'll still I might even
forgive but I will not forget because
they're gonna do it again but I think I
think you're I think what you're saying
is actually a good idea
you're like a cross between a green
beret and Alanis Morissette yeah I will
do things to you in a movie theater like
a pirate shirt
a pair of this racist Jim does everybody
just need to lighten up do you have it
what are your thoughts on this yeah I
mean look at Maxine Waters she's saying
you know her theory is if we harass
Eleni people that work for Trump they're
gonna quit yeah so he's probably gonna
hire somebody else to fill that slot
it's not gonna be at the point where
Trump's can be in the White House by
himself go ahead I got nobody more my
people getting harassed is a hundred
other people waiting for that job so
your theories not gonna work exactly
where do you see this going do you see
this kind of do you think see this
getting worse because they're going
crazy about the Supreme Court nomination
and it hasn't even happened yet yeah you
know the left I mean I'm surprised to
get hysterical and overreact on things
you know when they think that Roe vs.
Wade is going to overturn the first day
yes that new judge is there you know to
me like they really think that first day
it got overturned yeah it's not just
relax
yeah my concern is that they're already
at all you know from a scale of one to
ten they're already at an 11 mm so how
can this go it seems like it's gonna
stay at 11 I am someone who is upset a
lot but I do this thing where sometimes
when I'm upset I'm just kind of upset
yeah I don't think that my whole life is
over and that the world is going to end
and the people on the left aren't really
like that it's always everything's over
now the country's over everything's done
just once after Trump does something or
something happens I'd like to hear one
of them say I don't really care for that
right now they're like people who call
911 they sneeze more than once
yeah no they think they're dying they're
not always dying until you are that's
true too for the media basically cable
news is there 900 get up there and they
just go Pyrus sorry Greg let's get after
it
you always did you always talk about
taking the high road
hybl tall I have no choice I wear shirts
he wears blouses I'm just different
right should people do conservatives
trying to take the high road is it is it
pointless Greg may I call you Greg yes
better than what you call me at home I
have a competitiveness in me yeah I
don't like to see people succeed and I
hate most people
that's true so this is a happy time for
me I enjoy the whining and crying yes
when I was in the WWE
I loved being a bad guy yeah I loved
stepping on toys and seeing kids cried
there's just one of my favorite things I
enjoy the mass hysteria the Republican
president and the Republican Senate and
they're prevalent House gets to choose
their Supreme Court justice oh my god
you're gonna do they're gonna take away
our rights no they're gonna have right
rights all right agenda that's what you
vote and we voted so we can make those
choices so it's not your turn mm-hmm so
you'll have to wait but I guess I was
curious a lot I'm like were these were
these people like this before that
happened or did this do it to them no I
think because I feel like this the seed
of insanity had to be in them or the
seat of weak law they just brakes in
fairness in fairness we got to kind of
look at ourselves as who started to
fight we mean like usually when you win
you're kind of like I like to thank my
opponent good job we'll keep moving we
kind of went a little different way like
Trump likes to get on there and talk
about your mama
it's let's you know you beat you and
continue to let you beat you and every
time you think the woman said he'll walk
by with some salt and put it on you so
give you a wedge and at first the damn
Democrats didn't know what to do yeah
they come up in a ball and they're like
this is it right he's to stop doing this
now they're trying to fight but they
kind of fight like this they have it my
arms are too big to do that but maybe
you know Greg because you put your own
thing yeah I could try there you go
but I fight no still not a fight it's a
good point but we have we have to go but
I do think that a lot of this started it
with the Vietnam War I'm gonna go back
and say I feel that the moment that a
large group of the population demonize
the military called the baby killers and
that became part of the media narrative
that these people were at fault we've
never turned it hasn't stopped it hasn't
it hasn't stopped anyway sometimes I
come up with something sometimes you
don't suck yeah
that was uncalled was that too all too
much maybe I'm wrong no I could be wrong